democrats want to create a 911 style
commission
to investigate the capital riot on
january 6th
they do not want to create a commission
to investigate
the very well-funded blm organization
that burned the country down for six
months they don't want to investigate
antifa
which has been committing street
violence very serious street violence
for years at this point at a huge scale
they want to investigate
the horn guy and the guy who took the
podium on january 6th not excusing those
guys just saying
don't really seem comparable this is
obviously completely unnecessary this is
a a
partisan trick from the dems and so the
republicans
very rightly are saying now we're not
going to go along with that this is
completely
ridiculous the democrats hate that the
democrat they are losing their minds
over that tim ryan
who you might recall briefly ran for
president he's a
democrat in the house he took to the
floor of the house
to yell and scream and wave his arms
and say that republicans are not living
in reality
i want to thank the gentleman from new
york and the other republicans who are
supporting this and thank them for their
bipartisanship to the other 90 percent
of our friends on the other side of the
aisle
holy cow incoherence
no idea what you're talking about ben
gods benghazi you guys chased the former
secretary of state all over
the country spent millions of dollars we
have people
scaling the capital hitting the capitol
police with lead pipes across the head
and we can't get bipartisanship what
else has to happen in this country
cops this is a slap in the face to every
rank and file cop
in the united states if we're going to
take on china
if we're going to rebuild the country if
we're going to reverse climate change
we need two political parties in this
country that are both living in reality
and you ain't one of them yes nothing
says we're living in reality like
yelling and screaming
and pushing ridiculous canards that that
the right wingers are responsible for
killing cops and things like that
completely debunked even the new york
times and washington post admit it
who's really living in reality here the
problem
goes way way deeper than january 6th i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from rebel patriot
who says it's hard to win an argument
with a smart person
but it's damn near impossible to win an
argument with a stupid person
bill murray this is absolutely true this
actually gets into something
we were talking about yesterday which is
i love
engaging in political discussion i love
taking my opponent's argument seriously
that's what i've done
actually as the basis of my upcoming
book speechless controlling words
controlling minds available now for
pre-order you can get assigned
first edition copy by the way if you go
to premiere collectibles
the whole point of that book is to take
seriously the left's arguments and say
okay this is where it's wrong but this
is where we can learn something
but you'll notice that a lot of people
they don't want to do that it's just
like they plug their ears in and they
say la la la and they call you a racist
sexist whatever kind of
stupidity they'll say you have no
responsibility to engage in a
debate with them a debate is not
possible it's hard to convince someone
of anything but over time maybe you can
unless that person just thinks they're
the single smartest person in the room
in which case it's a completely
lost cause all right you've got to
protect yourself against that kind of
stuff and if you want to protect
yourself
i would go check out ring i love living
in the south i love having a nice big
southern house but having a big southern
house
means that you gotta keep track of
what's going on in the house what's
going on outside the house
make sure that everybody is safe ring
lets you do just that whether you
are in your living room or you're at the
office or you're
on vacation somewhere on the other side
of the world you can check out
who is at your door by the way with
motion detection the person at your
doorstep doesn't even need to ring the
bell
they'll just let you know you can see
and speak to them ring alarm is a
powerful
whole home security system that you can
easily install
yourself they've got security products
for every corner of your home inside and
out and you get to use this really
simple app i love it it helps me feel
safe especially when i'm traveling
and it's a great housewarming gift not
just because it's futuristic and cool
and keeps your friends safe
but it's not that expensive so you get
credit for a great gift you don't have
to shell out a lot of money start
protecting your home
today with ring alarm go to ring.com
knowles to get your ring alarm security
kit today
build the system that's right for your
home get it up and running in minutes
ring.com
knowles that is ring.com knowles january
6th the greatest threat to our nation
worse than pearl harbor
worse than 9 11. our democracy
was at stake because the horn guy stole
a podium or something i don't know it
wasn't
i don't mean to minimize what happened
on january i just can't
it's impossible not to minimize it when
you
talk about what happened compared to
what the left is saying happened
and by the way i know that we're not
allowed to compare this to the blm riots
that burned down the country and killed
a lot of people
but you have to i know they say that's
what a baptism you know what a baptism
is what a baptism
what about it let's compare what
happened
it's so it's so rich because the
arguments that democrats are making now
about the
the january 6th scarfuffle at the
capitol
are directly contradicting the arguments
that they were making for months and
months and months tammy duckworth
a democrat politician uh tweets out a
picture
of her office and it's got a smashed
window in it okay there's smash
i'm not saying these guys were totally
peaceful okay they
yes they smashed the window people are
saying that they killed cops that's just
a lie that's a complete lie we know that
isn't true
but yeah they smashed windows yep and
she tweets out don't believe the gas
lighting
this is what the so-called tourist visit
did to my office
okay you're right she's saying it's not
a tourist visit what happened on january
6. this was
violence except except this is awkward
we were told for months and months and
months
that when whole buildings and cities
were on fire
behind reporters on left-wing cable
networks
that that that amounted to fiery but
mostly peaceful protests
but you can burn a city down that's
mostly peaceful but you smash a window
that's the greatest act of violence ever
perpetrated in the united states
moreover we were told by one of the
leading
quasi-pseudo-intellectuals of the left
nicole hannah jones the head of the 1619
project
that property damage is
not violence yes it is disturbing to see
property being destroyed it is
disturbing to see
uh people taking property from stores
but these are things
and violence is when an agent of the
state
kneels on a man's neck until all of the
life is leeched out of his body
destroying property which can be
replaced is not
violence and to put those things uh to
use the exact same language to describe
those two things i think
really um it's not
it's not moral to do that so yes i think
any reasonable excuse me any reasonable
person would say
we shouldn't be destroying other
people's property but these are not
reasonable times
but these are not reasonable times what
she's saying is look yeah i don't want
to destroy people's property but
the times that we're living in call for
that and it's not violent it's tammy
it's not violence
destroying property which can be
replaced and by the way we're not
talking about
some guy's whole small business we're
not talking about someone's cherished
family possessions that blm burned down
when they burned down different
buildings we're just talking about your
window
you know come on property which can be
replaced
is not violence tammy now of course i
don't believe any of that
but according to their own logic they
must look this was a
this was a mostly peaceful tourist visit
wasn't it no
no of course not there's just one set of
standards for the
very deadly very destructive months-long
coast-to-coast insurrection of blm
and then there's another set of
standards for the riot and the guy who
took the podium and the horn guy who
danced around the capitol
and smashed some windows two and
bizarrely enough they're all being much
harsher on the horn guy than they are
on the domestic terrorists who targeted
civilians
to achieve their political ends in blm
and antifa
thankfully cocaine mitch not having any
of this nonsense
cocaine mr cocaine himself takes to the
floor of the senate
and says in as energetic a tone as we
ever get from mitch mcconnell so you
know
not very but still forcefully enough he
says he opposes
the january 6 commission after careful
consideration
i've made the decision to oppose the
house democrats slanted and unbalanced
proposal
for another commission to study the
events of january the 6th
there is has been
and there will continue to be no
shortage
no shortage of robust investigations by
two separate branches
of the federal government so mr
president it's not at all clear what new
facts or additional investigation
yet another commission could actually
lay on top of existing efforts by law
enforcement and congress
what is clear is that house democrats
have handled this proposal in partisan
bad faith going right back to the
beginning
so senator scarface here really hits on
the point of this commission
these incidents are already being
investigated and
people are being held to extremely
serious consequences
if they participated in the capital riot
they're not really being held to
consequences if they burn down the
country with blm
so the double standard still exists but
regardless the people who
rioted on january 6th are already facing
very serious consequences for it
so what's the point of this
senate investigation the point of it or
the house investigation the point of it
is
to give democrats a lot of power to go
after
any of their enemies andrew cuomo used
this
sort of investigative power to great
effect in new york if you if you have a
broad
uh scope to investigate your political
opponents
you can use that for anything
oh yeah so i think he spoke favorably
i think he tweeted favorably about the
january 6th thing let's go let's look
into his taxes let's look into his
personal life let's rate his computer
let's do this let's do that
it's just just a partisan tool mcconnell
absolutely right politically so savvy to
oppose this sort of thing
but tim ryan makes a point too never
thought i would say that but tim ryan
that
screechy crazy looney democrat at the
top of the show he does make a good
point he says if if
two political parties are not living in
reality then you can't have a country
now he's wrong when he says it's the
republicans not living in reality
because we get it we get the january 6th
thing we get the democrats are going to
use that to great effect
we also get that that's absurd and
hypocritical given
bl given the democrats overt endorsement
of and support for the blm riots in 2020
the sitting vice president
bailed the riders out of out of jail
right so obviously
they don't have a lot of credibility on
this point
but we must agree on reality if we are
to have a country together
and we don't agree on that reality
forget the riot thing or the
mostly peaceful riots or forget that for
a second
forget the election what happened in
2020 how dare you question
why the pennsylvania election officials
betrayed their own constitution why
you can't that's our democracy or
whatever okay get rid of all that for a
second
what's a man what's a woman
what's a human being what are we here
for
what are our pronouns what's a baby
what is america what is a nation
these are really really basic questions
and we don't agree on the answers and
it's not because we just sort of have
different perspectives man you know and
we're a pluralistic country no
it's that broadly speaking conservatives
are in touch with reality on those
fundamental questions
and increasingly the democrats
are off in outer space and this is
clear enough from the voice of her
generation
demi lovato who is now identifying as
multiple people if you want to avoid
this sort of confusion i would strongly
recommend you educate yourself with the
great courses
how much time do you waste how much time
do you waste
either staring slack jawed into space
or scrolling mindlessly past a bunch of
nonsense
use that time effectively you can do
that with
the great courses plus they've got a
library of over 13 000 audio and video
lectures
there's a ton of great topics to choose
from you can either do the practical
ones and how to build a better financial
plan stuff like that or you can do the
ones that i think are cooler which is on
like history
on literature on these these sort of
things that you probably didn't learn in
school even though you should have well
you can do it now you can let's say you
listen for five ten minutes
on your phone and then you switch it
over pick up right where you left off on
the computer when you get home where you
do it on your tv where it's just so
simple a great way to be productive and
get a lot smarter
what are you waiting for head on over to
the great courses plus today right now
sign up
for the quarterly plan to get an extra
month for free go to
thegreatcoursesplus.com
knowles do not miss out sign up and
redeem your
free month right now at
thegreatcoursesplus.com
knowles demi lovato i actually
you know i say this a lot whenever some
pop culture figure comes up i don't
really know who she is or what she does
i take it she's an actress or a singer
or something
demi lova she just kind of has that look
to her i'm sorry has that looked to
them because demi lovato is now
identifying
as she previously identified as
pansexual
she's now changing that to identify as
non-binary
i don't know exactly what the difference
is between those things
but i know that the effect of this
latter one is that she now identifies as
multiple people
she wants her preferred pronouns to be
they
and them and she announced this in
a pretty trippy video living in the
fourth dimension means existing
consciously and both time and space
hold on pause it right there already you
see we have a little problem about the
agreement and disagreement on reality
she says living in the fourth dimension
means living consciously in time and
space
that's called living in the third
dimension right i don't i'm not a
physicist but
i'm living in the in 3d right now i can
i see i've got
space i see understand volume and things
like that and i'm i'm living in time
i don't i know sometimes people call
time the fourth dimension i don't know
it seems a little
hippy-dippy to me so already i think the
inter-dimensional
aspect of this video has me primed and
ready to assume she's not going to be
totally coherent she goes on but for me
it means having conversations that
transcend the typical discourse
i want to take this moment to share
something very personal with you
over the past year and a half i've been
doing some healing and self-reflective
work
and through this work i've had the
revelation that i identify as non-binary
with that said i'll officially be
changing my pronouns to they them
pause pause again you can't do that
you can't that but it's my personal
choice i've had this revelation where
did you get this revelation from
who gave you this revelation that you
are multiple people the only
uh book where i have seen a sort of
revelation that an individual person is
multiple people
is this very old book sometimes called
the good book uh in which
uh uh one person shrieks out we
are legion we are you know and it's but
it's
that would be demons demons would be
doing because you a one person can't be
multiple people
and the smiling and i've done some
healing work
and some self-reflection you hear this a
lot from the they're always healing
because of some trauma that has been
done to them and i actually i don't even
mean to discount this yeah
people go through dramas that is life
that is part of life
but it's always we're healing and
because i'm healing you can't question
me
because i'm trying to recover from this
trauma you can't ever
question my delusions so i
am multiple people what does that mean
what does it mean to be they and them
i feel that this best represents the
fluidity i feel in my gender expression
and allows me to feel most authentic and
true to the person i both know i
am and still am discovering in this
first episode i'm excited to share with
you
what this means to me and what it may
look like for other people
i want to make it clear that i'm still
learning and coming into myself
and i don't claim to be an expert or a
spokesperson
i know this might be a new conversation
for many so i'm inviting my friend alok
someone i trust to spend time on this
platform alok is an author performer
and an important voice within the
non-binary community and beyond
their work to create visibility equality
and understanding has inspired me on my
healing journey
we'll discuss identity at large but also
take the time to personally reflect on
how i came into my truth
so that we like many others are able to
live our lives authentically
in just a minute i'm going to share
space with alok and dive deeper into
this conversation
if you told me michael
hundred thousand dollars on the line you
get one guess
what is the name of this lady's friend i
would probably guess alok
that's i wouldn't have guessed john or
bert you know i think alok sounds about
right
this video matters not because of
anything involving demi lovato i mean
the headline here is
entertainer begs for attention wow
not exactly a man bites dog story is it
so of course you know
entertainers do this all the time and
they just try to get more attention
particularly as their careers are
sort of on the on the way back down so
not not surprised here but the way that
demi lovato is doing this is by
just parroting it's like a parody of
leftist jargon she's just fitting all
the leftist slogans
my truth and self-discovery and healing
and this journey
into all into one sentence and it's you
know it's not going to be coherent
really from the beginning of it with the
fourth dimension stuff but even in
in this little bit she says we're going
to talk about the person
that i know i am and am still becoming
if you're still becoming that then you
don't know that you are that person
you can't you can't both be this firm
set person
and this other thing that you don't know
what it is that you're headed to
that just that alone is not possible but
it's actually multiple people right it's
they and it's them and
that sort of thing does not jibe with
any semblance of society it's this the
radical subjectivism of the phrase
my truth is enough just that alone is
enough
to destroy society i'm not being
hyperbolic here folks
i i don't mean to say that the bizarre
musings of some entertainer
are threatening to destabilize society
she is representing a very
popular ideology right now and if we
cannot agree that there is truth in tim
ryan's words if we can't agree on
reality
then we can't get along in society and
what she's saying is not even i disagree
with conservatives on reality she's
saying i don't believe there is reality
i'm saying it's my truth
and i'm becoming this radically
subjective thing and i know look i know
i look like a woman and everything and i
talk like a woman and i
obviously am a woman but i've had a
revelation that i know that my true self
who i
am not even that person yet but i know
that i am that person
is multiple people
well there goes society there it's over
it's not just
demi lovato uh demi lovato is joined in
her plea for attention
by anna paquin who is i guess another
actress
whom i've never heard of and she is
married to a male tv star
and she's now defending her bisexuality
she posts on instagram
quote i'm a hashtag proud bisexual who's
married to a wonderful human who happens
to be a man
if he doesn't have a problem with it why
should anyone else and then one
commenter on this post on insta
says i am getting tired of seeing bi
celebrities constantly advocate for it
only to end up conventionally married to
men with multiple children living out
the so-called white picket fence life
and then pacman responds she's very
angry she goes
oh yes the you aren't queer enough bs
and then she's defending herself she's
saying i am queer even though i'm living
a
perfectly conventional lifestyle with
this rich handsome guy
and we're just living a normal life i am
special darn it
i am i'm not like some of those other
gals who are married to guys and have
you know family and stable life i'm
bisexual i mean i'm not i like whatever
i guess i
kissed a girl once in college but i'm
but that makes me special
demi lovato i'm not i'm not just some
lady entertainer no i'm actually a
pansexual no scratch that i'm a
non-binary no scratch that i'm
whatever can get me more attention today
i'm so special and
i and i am so interesting is what
they're saying too
i know how it looks from the outside but
actually i'm much more interesting on
the inside
this comes back to the
classic problem i'm not the first one to
observe it
that when a civilization divorces itself
from i am that i am this is the name
that god gives himself when he's talking
to moses moses says who should i tell
them that you are and god says
i am who i am i am i am that i am
i am essence itself say okay
when you divorce yourself from i am you
are left with a very pathetic
and pitiful question which is who am i
and there's no end to that demi lovato
is going to be something else
in like three weeks i'd put money on it
how long has it been since she said she
was pansexual now she's
non-binary pretty i assume she's
demisexual too you with a name like that
you'd
say that's a groaner that's a groaner
sorry never mind
she'll be something else i'm sure anna
pacquiao will actually i'm a non i'm a
bisexual trans
this or i know it i know i look totally
normal but i'm actually super duper
special
if we want to have a society
you can't tolerate that stuff i know
that there's a huge the left is
obviously all in on it and there's a big
segment on the right the more
libertarian segment that says
hey whatever you want man i'm not a i'm
not a regular conservative i'm a cool
conservative you know i'm not a regular
mom i'm a cool mom
and yeah you could be a demi bi
non-trans whatever you can your name can
be alok or whatever
yeah no sorry if you want to
follow the tim ryan doctrine of living
in reality and i think we have to
i totally think we have to live in
society then you can't do that you can't
change the pronouns they're not yours to
change
frankly i don't think we should really
be changing our names such that people
named bruce can go by caitlyn caitlin's
a girl's name sorry buddy if you're a
guy
you can't be caitlin but it's but my
freedom it's not freedom
that's insanity and delusion and it
leads
society into licentiousness and lunacy
and so no we need boundaries
if we want a flourishing and free
society
the poem needs parameters the sonnet
needs constrictions if you want to have
the flourishing
and the freedom and the beauty that
comes from that sort of thing
you know ben is going to be talking
today about how the democrats
love january 6th they love it they need
it
they need when january 6 didn't turn out
exactly how they wanted they actually
just made up new aspects of it
i'll be talking about that on the show
me
i'm not going to say much more about
january 6th
that that whole discussion has left me
basically
speechless oh you knew it you knew it
even before i said it you knew it
head on over to speechlessbook.com to
pre-order your copy
today if you want an extra personal
touch
text speechless s-p-e-e-c-h-l-e-s-s
to five three four four five to
pre-order a signed copy
do not wait now i know some people said
michael i already pre-ordered a copy on
barnes noble or amazon or something
but now i want a signed copy i've got a
simple answer for you
just order another one that's cool you
just give the other one away as a
christmas present or something like that
or you just keep two
uh but michael i've already pre-ordered
the audible you know i do it all the
time i
will get the book on audible so i can
listen to it and i'll also get the book
physically so that i'll listen to it in
the car and then i'll flip over and i'll
read some at night and then i'll flip
back and forth
go do it get three four ten copies i
don't know pre-order today
and understand the pc police better than
they understand themselves we'll be
right back
so often on this show and in the broader
culture we focus in
on how these crazy woke ideologies
spread throughout social media
and you've got the demi lovato of it all
and the anna pequen
and the a lot of kooky people who are
not celebrities
but don't forget social media they're
just media it's just a medium
and you can transmit insanity on there
or you can transmit
serious ideas so you got the demi lovato
hyper subjectivism the hyper
subjectivism of
intersectionality and the woke people
and the 1619 project
which say that whatever i
say will constitute reality because
everything is socially constructed sex
is socially constructed history is
socially constructed so it's all just
whatever we say it is it's a kind of
premise of political correctness is that
you change the words you change the
culture
but then there was a great video i saw
this one girl
super smart posts a tick tock where
instead of just focusing on her
you know super high after seven bong
hits kind of
weird subjectivist pseudo philosophy she
uses
facts and logic to explain how there is
a reality to the universe and by the way
the substratum of that reality the the
essence that keeps the being that keeps
the whole thing going that undergirds
all of it
is god who exists have y'all ever heard
of the theory of general relativity it's
what einstein is famous for
in his calculations he started to
realize that the universe was not
eternal
it had a beginning now this leads us to
the law of causality
everything that came to be needs a cause
so einstein clearly knew that if the
universe had a beginning
it needed a cause let's go to the big
bang theory there was no space
no time and no matter before the big
bang the universe emerged out of
nothingness
what does that mean since it's
impossible for the universe to be able
to create itself
because it didn't exist in order to be
able to create itself
nature and the universe itself was just
a big effect
that was caused by what are we left with
an extremely powerful
extremely intelligent precise given the
precision that our universe was created
with
personal entity that is capable of
existing
outside of time space and matter that
can't be nothing but god
do i need to sign up for tick tock now i
didn't i thought tick tock
was just a bunch of crazy people
spouting off and then a bunch of other
people jiggling around
and i figured this is not and and also
xi jinping stealing all of our
information
so i assume there's no reason for me to
be on tick-tock
but if i can go on tick-tock and just
hear popular apologetics and
very strong and common-sense arguments
for the existence of god maybe i've got
to sign up and get an account
do you see the difference between what
this gal is saying on tiktok
and say what demi lovato is saying in
her social media post
they're both giving their visions of the
universe right they're both
describing i guess even their identity
or where they find themselves in the
universe
but with demi lovato's you can't make an
argument
for or against it because she's just
saying it's all just about my personal
feeling my personal private revelation
that i had of who i am but i don't even
know who i am yet even though i know who
i am but i don't know who i'm going to
be
but i am who i'm going to be and
therefore you just have to believe me
and if you don't you know you're kind of
a meanie and you'll hear more from my
friend alok or whatever
this gal is coming out and saying hey
you have faculties of reason there is
an observable reality that we can
perceive and then we can use our reason
to work that out have conceptions right
and follow
arguments to their logical conclusion
and because this world
is is caused because we're all sort of
caused beings and contingent beings even
then you've got to trace that all the
way back
to god to an unmoved mover to an
uncaused cause
that's not just a hey man wouldn't it be
weird if it were like this that's a
that's a logical argument
if we are going to have a society that
is living in reality
we got to base it on that you can't it's
not
possible to be living in reality if you
base it on the demi lovato thing because
demi
it's not even just that she's wrong it's
that she doesn't accept
reality that reality exists at all but
unfortunately
the demi lovato theory of the world is
is much more fashionable at the moment
than that girl's theory of the world
also also thomas aquinas theory of the
world that she's
she's reciting the trans ideology is
more popular at the moment
you always hear this from from the left
they say well look sarah silverman made
this point the other day
she said there's never been a case of a
man competing in girls sports and then
beating the girls at the sports and
taking their prizes and stuff and that's
just not true there's a famous case
right now working its way up the courts
of a dude who just keeps beating girls
at high school track
but we got another story this weekend
just tuck this one away in your your
quiver
so that you got another little detail
when people bring up that bogus argument
haley davidson who's a dude uh competed
and won a professional title in women's
golf last week
he you know he identifies as a woman but
he's a dude he
also previously competed in men's
college golf athletics
and he's now hoping to be eligible for
the ladies pga
the professional golf association so
this is
um bad there's just evidence that when
the libs tell you that there's no
not a single case of men competing in
women's sports and beating them at it
there are men basically always do that
when they compete openly
and they usually do it when they compete
surreptitiously as well
and pretend to be women but the issue is
much deeper than sports
also going back to sarah silver when
sarah silverman pointed out that
the opponents of the transgender
ideology don't really care about women's
sports
they're right i don't i don't care i'm
not going to watch these golf matches or
whatever you call it golf i don't even
know about you
golf bouts these golf rounds i'm not
going to watch it i don't really care i
care about
the reality it's me and tim ryan against
the world
the issue is much deeper than sports
usually i only read letters that i get
on mailbag day uh this one i'm going to
read to you this
really moved me i got this letter
yesterday from a listener in italy
it was written in english it's a little
bit choppy english but basically well
written and so uh
the regardless though even if it weren't
well written the content is
really what we're talking about here
subject
i was a sad trans and then i
detransitioned and now i'm happy
message hello michael i'm writing to you
from italy i'm a 30 years old woman
when i was 18 i was involved with the
trans movement because my family abused
me and i was confused and had the bad
luck to meet trans people
who convinced me that i was a boy they
were
trans people from the italian trans
rights associations
i always had been very feminine but they
somehow convinced me taking advantage of
my
suffering to go on testosterone and to
mutilate my chest
after some years i understood that i
fell in their trap
because trans people are narcissistic
and abusive too like my family
like everybody right to some degree that
people are all kind of broken people
now i am a 30 year old woman and i am
happy
and living the joy of being a woman
i am still facing the irreversible
damage done to my body but i can still
be a mother
and take care of my future kids and it
makes me happy not having fully
fully believed their lies ps when i told
them that i was de-transitioning i lost
all their
friendship they bullied me told me to
sue us to commit suicide etc
and no one of them wanted to be my
friend anymore thank you for bringing
light on this topic
yours a happy woman from italy
there are many stories of people
de-transitioning you're going to get
more and more of those stories because
this has been a social contagion this
insane ideology
and there have been parents and schools
and
the whole culture is encouraging little
kids to mutilate their bodies
and the vast majority are going to come
to regret that
this point too it occurs to me where you
say
the trans movement is manipulative of
course it is
it's its very essence is manipulation
because the idea
here is that you have the right to
and you ought to totally
transform reality using your own hands
using the surgery or using the
hormones or using whatever to better
accord with your view of the world
and that you can do that that one but
you can't
you can't if we're going to live in tim
ryan's reality
you can't do that there's a limit to
your ability to manipulate it's a very
western idea
that it goes back really into into the
heart of our tradition
that we can transform the world through
our art through our
craft through our skill and we can and
we've done this to great effect
but there's a difference between taking
the reality that we live in and
from that creating the beautiful art of
a cathedral or some beautiful painting
or some beautiful sculpture
and abusing that and ignoring reality
and creating something
hideous or that is contrary to what it
truly is or ought to be
there's a big difference here we can you
know we have our freedom
we can use our freedom in accordance
with
reality and with the natural order and
the moral order
or we can abuse that freedom and use it
to licentiousness
and use that freedom to pervert and
destroy and mutilate the world
and it's not they're not the same thing
and there are real consequences here
very happy to this person who wrote in
that she is doing better now
and has gotten out of this craziness and
anyone who's considering getting into it
i would uh
maybe send them that letter send them
that little clip and just let them know
there's a there's a dark side here too
i've interviewed people who've
de-transitioned
years past who who talk about how
what a horrible thing it did to their
lives because you can't
you can't go back you can try to fix
certain things thankfully this woman
hadn't
gone so far that it was completely
irreversible but some things were
irreversible she said she mutilated her
body she was very pretty and she
mutilated her body
and you can't totally go back from that
either better to
cut it off while you still can before
before really it's too late
this is all part of an anti-human
ideology and this anti-human ideology
expresses itself in various ways it's
not
just the gender thing it's not even just
the abortion thing that we it's not just
the overpopulation thing it's not just
the idea
that we need fewer humans and the humans
who are here need to be different than
they are
this gets down to this weird
impulse i've noticed on the left to
remove human beings from their special
place in the order of creation
the conservatives believe christians
believe
that human beings are made in the image
of god we have dominion over the land
and the sea
we need to be good stewards of this
creation
we need to use our freedom in accordance
with god's will
we have a special place there is a
difference between me
and a crab and a little crab on the
beach
but what the left is saying increasingly
is there's not much of it there's a
little difference of degree but come on
it's actually it's just
the way evolution worked and just you
can't you can't say that a human being
is greater or more developed more
advanced
more sophisticated than a little crab
there was a video that just went viral
over the past few days
of a crab digging in the sand and you
see the crab he's on the beach
and he's digging in the sand and he's
pulling the sand up
from the little hole
so okay there's the crab and he's dig
dig dig and it's going up and up and up
around him
the person who posted this by the way is
i think an assistant professor
and wrote in that kind of goofy script
you know capital lowercase capital
lowercase
but humans are the most advanced species
the implication
that humans are not the most advanced
species because there's a little crab
and he digs up the sand and he covers
himself up in this little hole
when i watched this video and i thought
so your your best argument
against human beings having a special
place in the order of creation
is that crabs can dig a hole it takes
them a long time but they can dig a hole
and i thought you know
i can dig a hole
can this assistant professor not dig a
hole in the sand because maybe then
maybe she's got a problem
in the order of creation but she
continues she goes
we are not the most advanced species no
species is more advanced than any other
each species is uniquely adapted to its
environment this crab could judge
any other species for their inability to
build sand houses etc
as being less advanced it's all a matter
of perspective
did you catch the problem with her
statement it's not about the sand houses
i mean yes we can build better sand
houses than the crab can but
no it's not about the sand houses it's
not about what it's the word
judge she says this crab could judge
any other species but the crab can't
judge any other species
because judgment requires a rational
will
and an intellect and the crab doesn't
have either
this is not my own understanding of the
world
i don't think that i came up with this
brilliant idea on my own
we've known this since at least
aristotle and probably we knew it before
aristotle
the fact that i have an intellect that i
can
perceive and conceive things in a way
that is
far more sophisticated not just a little
different in degree but different in
kind from how the crab can
perceive things is something that
separates us and also the rational will
all beings have a sort of very basic
will in the sense that
the the crab needs nutrition so it eats
things so that the
the tree needs nutrition drinks up water
but it's not conscious of that it's not
freely choosing these things these are
just instinct
the rational this is why when a gorilla
kills somebody you don't put the gorilla
on trial it would be very crazy to put
the gorilla on trial the gorilla does
not have a free
rational will the gorilla can't make
moral choices
it's why you don't throw lions in jail
for killing the lion is just doing what
it what it must do according to its
nature
but we don't need to do that we actually
can make moral choices because we have a
rational will all of which is
denied by the this anti-human left which
wants to pretend that we're all just
kind of the same thing man and ever
and all the things that we think
separate us from the bugs and the crabs
they're just delusions we tell ourselves
but you're nothing you're no better
than the bugs
if that's science if the people who say
that there's no difference between
humans and crabs and the people who say
that babies aren't really babies and the
people who say
that little girls should mutilate their
bodies to look more like boys because
they're going through a phase or
something
if that is science then i'm out
and i think there's no wonder
that the public health authorities have
no credibility because
not only have they gotten all of that
wrong all these basic aspects of our
life that we know are just bs
the idea that you can change your sex or
whatever the babies aren't babies but
they've also gotten their very specific
job wrong
the very specific job deb protect us
during an epidemic they've gotten it
wrong every single step of the way the
former surgeon general jerome adams who
famously tweeted out stop
buying masks people after fauci lied to
everybody and said
that masks don't work and then later on
he said masks do work and then
it's sort of unclear even what kind of
masks you're what are you talking about
but he said
he made a political decision just to
save the masks for his
his own nurses
jerome adams goes on tv and he says the
cdc
and other public health authorities they
kind of botched the rollback of the
lockdown
this new cdc guidance is telling us that
these vaccinations are so
incredibly effective that if you're
fully vaccinated
if you're fully vaccinated meaning two
weeks out from your last dose
that the benefit of additional masking
and social distancing
is minimal i think this was an
appropriate call based on the science
the science is sound
i think that uh the play call was right
but they fumbled the ball at the one
yard line in terms of
communicating this to the public in
terms of engagement lots of my public
health officials have told me
they are upset they were blindsided by
this new information
i think you missed the nuance about
protecting yourself versus protecting
an organization and i think that again
it was a little bit of whiplash for the
american public
in terms of them saying just a week
before keep your mask on
and then all of a sudden they're saying
now you can take them off
there was there was a little bit of
whiplash and you're saying well it's not
the science that was wrong it's the
messaging and the communication well you
know don't forget public health
officials they're
half scientists but half politician the
job is really to be political and to
communicate with people
and to guide policy and so if they blow
that they they really blow the
key aspect of the job but also
if they lie right now you know my my
views on masks we'll just leave it at
that i know that i know that youtube is
very
very tricky about how you how honest one
can be about one's views
uh but i think i think we all we all
know what i'm saying here
in fouchy's view though the masks are
really super duper important and they
really work right that's what he says he
believes
but he told people they weren't because
he felt he wanted to communicate
something with them
and then later he pepsi has just told us
he doesn't think that once you're
vaccinated you need a mask
but he told people they do need a mask
and then later he told them they don't
need a mask and he admitted he said well
you know look yeah
i just thought we had to be you know
communicating this sort of thing because
i wanted people to continue to wear it
until more people get vaccinated but of
course it's the case that if you're
vaccinated you don't really need the
mask
if you lie to people
about just even about your views forget
about lying about the truth or falsehood
but just about even your own views
you're being dishonest in that way
and then you tell them your true views
and then you tell them that they lied
you lied to them
and then you tell them that it's good
that you lied to them
they're going to stop believing you
because we prefer to live in reality
with tim ryan
i don't think tim ryan lives in reality
but he says he does
and if you're going to disregard that
reality we have no reason to go along
with you
we have to take matters into our own
hands because we're free people and we
have self-government at least in theory
this is what we should have done from
the beginning i'm very pleased to see
that utah
is banning public schools and
universities from issuing mass mandates
not just saying hey schools and
universities do whatever you want
no utah is issuing a big government
regulation
an awesome terrific very conservative
big government regulation on the more
local areas the schools and the
universities
saying no you cannot have a mass mandate
they're allowing counties still to do
this so there is still localism here
it is still a little nuanced but
perfectly fine
i suppose but they are saying no you
can't do it
in order to protect people's freedom but
also people's american way of life and
also people's human dignity that we
shouldn't just
put filthy cloths over our face and
muzzle ourselves take away our
our distinctive human trait that we can
speak that makes us the political animal
we're not going to let you take that
away from people limiting
the willfulness of the universities and
the schools
to protect the freedom of the people who
go there i
love that i hope that more places do
that more states
a lot of politicians that were trying to
undermine their democratic
accountability
right they're trying to minimize
self-government send everything off to
the experts
and even when they're going to be asked
tough questions
to not not even permit reporters to do
that
remember democracy dies in darkness
trump the most transparent pro
pro press president in history probably
he would
talk at length for hours to report as
he'd make fun of them but he would talk
he was open
to them joe biden doesn't do that sort
of thing and lori lightfoot now
in chicago mayor of chicago is saying
she's only going to grant one-on-one
interviews
to black and brown journalists
she is this is according to a spokesman
who says that now she's in her two-year
midway point as mayor and she's only
going to give one-on-one interviews to
black or brown journalists it is
tired and cliche and pointless to to
observe that if the situation were
reversed of course
this would be an international incident
and there would be a huge outcry but
i i don't even want to focus on that
point because it just doesn't matter
there's just different sets of standards
right there's one set of standards for
the
black lives matter terrorists who burn
the country to the ground and
there's one set of standards for the
horn guy and the guy who took pelosi's
podium
and the standards for the horn guy are
much much harsher than for the blm
terrorists and that's just the way it is
and so
lori lightfoot a black mayor can come
out and say i'm only going to give
interviews to black and brown
journalists and
the reason here of course is
statistically she's looking and saying
black people vote democrat much more so
than
white people do so that's going to give
me a political advantage but also if
you're already saying i'm going to
discriminate on the journalists i talk
to
then they can get much more specific far
beyond just the skin color they can say
okay there's a leftist journalist
there's another leftist
there are plenty of black people who are
conservative i don't think she'd give an
interview to candace owens for instance
but or larry elder or somebody but she
this is just an excuse
to discriminate and she's going to get
away with that because
the sense of reality that we have is
contrary to reality itself the ideology
being pushed on us
is that this country is in a white
supremacist
patriarchal christian theocracy and of
course it's totally the opposite of that
it's totally the only racial
discrimination the only racism that's
permitted and actually promoted by
society
is against white people and to a lesser
degree against asian people but also
against asian people
in university emissions and things like
that
the only religion that it's perfectly
fine to castigate and mock
is christianity that our perception of
things is very different from reality if
we
tim ryan is very barely but makes a good
point
if we are going to have a country we
need to be living in reality and that
means conservatives need to get a little
bit tougher about articulating and
enforcing that reality a point i make at
great length in my opinion with
speechless controlling words controlling
minds available now for pre-order
i'm michael knowles i'll see you
tomorrow
michael knowles show is produced by ben
davies executive producer jeremy boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
well show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show
you